hi thank you so much for inviting me
here i am like pumped beyond words like
I can't even like I'm not even
caffeinated I'm just like yes so thank
you again my name is Raquel velas you
can find me on Twitter I'm rockbot and
it's like rocky and a robot that's me um
rockbot and i work at Storify I'm a
front-end engineer at Storify if you
wanted to learn more about social media
and journalism and all that stuff I'm
happy to talk about that or we could
talk about robots is there something
wrong good no oh okay it's let's get
started first of all it's so warning
there may be math they're actually there
will be math if any of you have an
allergic reaction to math the way that I
have an allergic reaction to space it's
okay just hold out like bear with me it
will get awesome I promise and there
will be a demo so yeah okay so a little
bit about me and I have been a
practicing roboticist for about 10 years
now and believe it or not before I went
into robotics I wanted to be a filmmaker
my whole goal in life was to be the next
Steven Spielberg and moved back to
California and went in Academy Award and
be just super awesome but then I was a
high school student and I got invited to
a society women engineers event in
Princeton University and there were
bunch of Engineers and there's this one
mechanical engineer who's like yeah
these engineers are all really awesome
whatever great but I built this in my
class and she whips out this robot and
puts it on a table and I was like oh oh
my god I I learned three things that day
first that it is possible to build
robots I didn't know that i thought that
robots were just figments of our
imagination that we saw in movies and on
TV and in write about in books and then
the second thing I learned was that
women could build robots because that
also didn't occur to me and then third
was that I already had the skill set
that I needed to get started uh and that
would just completely blew my brains and
I just was like okay that's it films
over robots all the
so I I made it my life goal to just
start building robots and my very first
robot I was in high school and I had a
lot of privilege but I got to build this
awesome guy his name is Adrian and he is
a search and rescue robot his job is to
follow this line and and find victims
made out of aluminum foil it was really
awesome it won a couple of wards at
different competitions internationally
so if you don't think that you can start
playing around with robots this is a
really good starter actually at the time
Lego Mindstorms if you help me people
apart of Lego Mindstorms excellent so at
the time and I was 17 18 years old at
that point and it turned out that the
average user of Lego Mindstorms was a 35
34 year-old male so like anybody can
just get started and start playing with
robots so that was high school and I
knew I had to be playing robots for
guests of my life so I went ahead and
just kept going I went to Cal Tech to
get my my mechanical engineering degree
and this was my second robot or rather
this was my second robot um this is Bob
this is a caltex first entry into the
darpa grand challenge at which if you've
never heard of that it's a race for
autonomous viet autonomous vehicles in
the desert so basically driverless cars
you've probably seen them before but
this was one of the first instances of
anybody ever actually doing that and
this was my second robot which is kind
of a huge jump between the two but
whatever it was awesome and I'd like to
note that the reason we had to use a
Chevy Tahoe is because the entire back
of this vehicle is full of computers
full of computers our iphones can
probably do about half of what that does
now but at the time it was my oh my god
okay so after like during and after
college there were some more robots and
at chris mentioned i worked at NASA JPL
I did some DoD stuff I did an internship
in Germany at doing a biomechanical
research using to KUKA robots which I'll
get into it in a second and another a
couple other robots that I can't really
talk about sir but if you want to talk
about any of those other robots just
come holler at me so basically I was in
this world of traditional robotics and I
learned a few things for example i
learned that robots come from research
it's this really really slow academic
process and robots are really hard
they're difficult it's it takes a lot of
effort you have to do need to write
these papers and you have to present
them and then you have to hope that
nobody else has presented anything like
it so that you can get the credit for it
up and then you also kind of need your
PhD because phd's do research research
costs a lot of money and they kind of
need and I put this in quotes because
i'm debating this but they need object
oriented and threading because of all
the vast vast amounts of sensor data
that's coming in so you know whatever
great I also learned that if you're
wondering about robot domination not
going to happen any time soon you're
more likely to get hit by a zombie
apocalypse than Skynet just so you know
if you want to know why I asked me about
it later or or come to the node BOTS
event tomorrow and you'll find out why
that's not happening anytime soon so
then I took a little bit of a break from
robotics I was getting a little tired of
being alone in a lab and it was cold and
this whole academic process was really
slow and yeah so I decided to do
something that kind of filled my instant
gratification thing and that was web
development I was like hey I can press
refresh and boom look I can see what's
there and that's awesome i don't have to
worry about
and then porting it over to the robot
and hoping and praying that that the
robot will still work after everything
that there doesn't isn't like magic
smoke or something I can just literally
press refresh and see what happens but
then then you know Here I am playing
around a node and having some fun and
then there's this this guy you may have
met him um who decided that he wanted to
start playing around with hardware and
node and I was like okay that's that's
cool you know no big deal and then there
was this other guy yeah who decided that
you know really robots hard word one
okay robots yeah okay cool and I saw his
at his his talk at node conf last year
and and it was really cute there was
this little robot and he was he was
running around a stage he's trying to
avoid these obstacles and I was like um
but then I said wait a second what if we
could do more what if we could make them
smarter what if we could do stuff so I
did um so I basically have created this
module call vector which I'll get into a
little bit more and the quick version of
it it is it's a linear algebra module
specifically for robotics just kind of
as a starter so let's put that further
ado let's get into it a little bit of
robotics 101 artificial intelligence
let's talk about what that means what is
artificial intelligence anyway and
really it's it's simple you're giving
something else the ability to make
decisions simple right so for example
let's say you have this you know
adorable little robot who's trying to
avoid obstacles you could you could
really program this with a simple if
else sort of thing right so if I'm
driving along and I see something and I
can't go through it then stop move back
turn a little bit and then
try again if I hit something you know or
I'm close to something stop move back
turn a little bit and then keep going
until I get through away from the
obstacles that's that is absolutely
artificial intelligence that's called
object or obstacle avoidance simple but
what if you need something a little bit
more complex so robotics 101 again
serial manipulators who's heard of a
serial manipulator okay I promise you
you probably have all actually seen with
serial manipulators you just didn't know
what they were called this is a cuca
robot it is a serial manipulator
basically it has a series of joints
connected by links this particular
cooker robot is writing a version of the
Martin Luther Bible why I don't know
does it matter not really I would like
to note that cuca is a German company
and maybe that has something to do with
Martin Luther I don't know anyway so
great so let's kind of now okay guys the
math is going to start just brace
yourselves um so want to come okay so
this is a serial manipulator once again
you may have seen these in building cars
how many have seen those those big
robots that kind of piece cars together
yeah exactly that's a serial manipulator
that's all it is and okay so the whole
point of this is like I said there are a
series of joints and they're connected
by links and you have some sort of base
and you have some sort of claw we're
gonna call it the end effector because
that's more scientific sounding we're
going to call it the claw that just
called the claw okay so we have a claw
and we have a basin and each we have a
couple of joints and and and the way we
represent this mathematically as we look
at frames of reference and so each joint
by convention has a frame of reference
so I'm going to use my arm because
that's also a classic serial manipulator
um so we have a shoulder joint right and
we have an elbow joint like this and
then we have like a claw right and and
so there are two major pieces of zero
manipulators in terms of mathematically
doing fun stuff with them so there's
forward kinematics in the way that
forward kinematics works is we have a
bunch of inputs that are angles and then
out we get a position so what does that
look like each of these joints are
angles right so got my shoulder angle
and I've got my elbow angle and then i
have the position of my claw right so
basically forward kinematics says if I
put in a bunch of angles I will get out
a position does that make sense cool all
right so then that actually has a single
solution makes sense right there's only
two inputs I'm always gonna get the same
I'm going to get an output no matter
what inputs I put in its going to be
static then there's inverse kinematics
which should be pretty self-explanatory
basically we know the position of our
claw and then what are the angles of our
joints this is a harder problem to solve
because if for example i have my claw
here well I could have my joints in this
configuration or I could have it in this
configuration right so it's a little bit
more difficult but for right now we're
not going to worry about that just
understand forward kinematics inverse
kinematics make sense cool all right now
it's going to get a little bit more
Matthew sorry guys so the way that we do
this representation is stuff is we use
matrices matrices are your friend
especially in robotics they're awesome I
love them if they scare you we will we
will clean out the spiderwebs and it's
going to be fine it's going to be okay
but the whole point of this this is
specifically a homogeneous matrix and
the way that it works is we have two
major components to it we have a
rotational component and a position
component and so for each frame
frame has a homogeneous matrix
associated with it okay so for every
single joint think about it every single
joint has rotation information and
position information so if i change the
angle of my shoulder the position and
the position of my elbow is going to
change right and then similarly if i
change the angle of my elbow then the
position of my claw is going to change
so you can basically come up with all
this information and now we have a
manipulator cool yeah I need head Bob's
or else I'm just going to be like mmm
okay so now how do we connect them all
together and it's just some simple
training so we have frames for each of
our joints we chain them together and we
get all of our information that we need
to go from beginning to end cool right
yeah all right I'm gonna pretend you
thought that was awesome too okay so now
comes vector we're going to let the
computer do all the hard stuff so we're
gonna let vector do all of the matrix
math we don't have to worry about I'm
not you don't have to worry about how to
multiply matrices together or how to
extract position information or how to
define rotational information or
anything like that we're just gonna let
back to do it and I should also note
that vector is literally just a linear
algebra module I'm using it for the
particular case of a manipulator but you
could also use it for things like
computer vision or a game engine
graphics or a whole bunch of other
really awesome things swarm robots all
that stuff it can all be used using
vector okay so like I said forward
kinematics with vector so we have our
our crazy matrix but now with some code
right you could just got you have your
homogeneous matrix you've got your
vector the irritations and then you have
your whole bunch of frames and so what
we're doing is we're just defining each
frame as having some rotation and some
position and then we're multiplying it
again each frame to the one before it
and then at the end we have some
at the end and this is just forward
kinematics I won't go into inverse
kinematics cuz yeah so are we good yeah
give me something come on all right
thank you ok I should note vectors not
perfect I know that that's why it's open
source help all right so demo time if
this doesn't work it's going to be ok
because i have a video but let's see
hopefully you can see this so we're
using facetime uh yeah and we're going
to turn this on and ok please wake up
yes move the console dang it oh we're
okay we're okay we're okay we're good No
ah this is what happens you shouldn't
said anything uh ok has
that did it wait yes alright cool can
everybody see this or some version
thereof can you see the little Johnny 5
okay so like I said you have the first
joint which is like your shoulder and
what we can do is we can kind of turn it
around like that yeah and then we have
our second joint and we can very
carefully do that and so that's forward
kinematics all I've done is just I've
put in the input of angles for each
joint and I can see on the screen where
the end effector / claw is obviously I
don't have a claw on here it's just
little Johnny Five sticker I'll let you
guys do the imagination stuff ok so yes
we've got this now inverse kinematics is
a little bit more interesting right so i
can just kind of grab the end and i'm
calculating mathematically what the
angles should be and so it doesn't even
have to be I could you know drag it to
the end here and then kind of come back
and it's doing a little dance the video
broke you see it all right well anyway
that's our demo thank you
and I have another video just in case my
backup or my extra backup or my hardware
my backup hardware didn't work but
anyway see how that was cute right um so
what so what indeed uh wait hon I have
to fix something I'm gonna turn that off
okay try it again okay hope you for
tweeting about me and it's so cute okay
so right so great um except you probably
some of you may have rumbas at home some
of you may have heard about those
military drones so you will be playing
with node copter tomorrow so you may
have heard of asimo the honda robot that
can like climb stairs and run great that
stuff's been solved this is this is
boring by comparison so why even bother
right why bother with JavaScript robots
and so yeah fair enough at this point in
time I wanted I really desperately
wanted to kind of prove that node was
better than C++ and Python either it's
not or I didn't have enough time I'm not
really sure but we'll leave that
question for another day the fact of the
matter is the traditional robotics
industry is kind of done already right
like I mean like it's ready it's
well-established it has tapped tools and
funding the smartest people in the world
are working there great and and us in
our little our little JavaScript node
BOTS we were we're just getting started
um it it fortunately doesn't cost that
much money this whole setup probably
cost me like 50 bucks but you know it's
a couple of pennies I don't have 50
million dollars although if anybody has
50 million dollars i will take it um and
and it's just it's just us right it's
just us we don't have PhDs but we know
JavaScript and I don't know how many of
you know python or C++ or any of the
other multiple languages that you could
be using but we all know JavaScript so
let's let's let's reframe this right so
in traditional robotics there's research
and papers and
caught the reason they have so much
money because it costs so much money
again compile load boot hope pray magic
smoke Oh God and you have to get a PhD
where is in JavaScript community right
in our little j/s community everything's
open source forget papers forget you
know research and top-notch labs etc
I've just put vector out there you can
go ahead and use it go ahead and fix it
make it better that's what we can do and
and you know you just refresh the page
any time things don't work just request
refresh the server breaks because you
overturned it oops buy another one for
twenty bucks it's not a big deal and you
don't need to get a few cheat you can
just get started just get started plus I
feel like with our powers combined
without the the the the obstacles of
getting a PhD or having to find millions
of dollars from the federal government
or whatever yadda yadda yadda we might
actually be able to use a new tool to
solve complex problems that have been
complex forever sensor fusion is a
really really difficult problem that's
the idea of having multiple sensors with
all these streams of data and then
trying to parse that into something that
makes some intelligible sense we're kind
of doing that with big data right why
don't we just kind of bring that over to
robotics what if we could solve that
problem better than the academics can ma
I no sirree okay but yeah why not so go
build a robot and then tell me all about
it because I really really want to know
what you guys come up with thank you
very much
you